magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman i want to
start today by talking about president
joe biden's upcoming supreme court pick
as many of you have no doubt heard by
now
the oldest liberal justice on the court
stephen breyer is going to be retiring
and joe biden is going to get to pick
or nominate rather a replacement which
is subject to confirmation by the senate
now joe biden made a promise during the
campaign
that he would select a black woman which
would be if confirmed the first black
woman ever on the united states supreme
court um he confirmed that that's still
the plan gen saki his white house press
secretary confirmed it and i believe joe
biden has also been asked about it and
confirmed that as well
the american right
is now starting a campaign
to make the case that this is extremely
discriminatory and essentially racist
to anyone who is not a black woman in
other words the way that many are
framing it and we're going to look at
laura ingram in a moment who's doing
this is
if you are excluding anyone who is not a
black woman
it is by definition discriminatory and
or racist against those individuals
this is wacky and as someone who is not
a wokester and not into corrosive
identity politics i'm going to explain
to you why these people are wrong but
let's first listen to laura ingram like
everything else joe biden touches his
supreme court selection process is in
shambles
candidate biden he thought he was being
really woke and so cool by pledging to
nominate an african-american woman to
the high court but of course he was also
effectively discriminating against a
vast majority of the adult population
uh-oh and now even liberal websites like
slate thinks he has himself in a bind
claiming that biden's pledge has
backfired and needlessly tokenized
future nominees so let me remind you
i am
not an identity politics guy i have
spoken out for a decade about uses of
identity to silence
or to um uh exclude
uh you all if you've been watching this
show listening to my podcast for a while
you know that
um let's go through this now in that
context in steps first of all is what
joe biden is doing
unique and the answer is no it is not
here is donald trump saying
i'm choosing between women only for this
next seat and the crowd cheered great i
will be putting forth the nominee next
week it will be a woman
right
uh it wasn't only donald trump who did
this ronald reagan did the exact same
thing paul's continuing to show he runs
better among men than women reagan took
a dramatic step today to reach out for
female support
now i'm announcing today that one of the
first supreme court vacancies in my
administration
will be filled by the most qualified
woman i can possibly find oh whoa hold
on a second now you can say well they
were all wrong to do that david okay
fine you could take that position
but were you actually saying it at the
time or are you saying it now
that they already put women on the
courts and you no longer
really have to say anything about it
it's very easy now to say well they were
all wrong none of them should have done
it but that's not really the most
important thing to think about i'm
putting for context that this is not
unique so a lot of the criticism of
biden is hypocritical but the most
important thing is the context that
matters here the supreme court was
established in 1789
from 1789 until 1967
that's
178 years
every single justice
was
white and male
okay
178 years and during that time we had
slavery in the united states for roughly
80 years of that 178 years we had
slavery of black people
and an all-white male court so it's okay
and it's notable when we say hey we now
have a black person on the court
which came in 1967 with thurgood
marshall it's not racist it's not
discriminatory it's look at the makeup
of the country and look at the makeup of
the court and at this point with so many
qualified black jurists how have we not
had one it's okay to point that out
you're not participating in toxic and
corrosive identity politics let's give
another example from 1789 until 1981 we
had all men on the court that's
192 years every single justice was a man
so it's okay and notable to say
given the history of qualified uh women
lawyers judges here's finally the first
woman on the court uh when sandra day
o'connor was nominated to the court
there has never been an asian person on
the supreme court native american
pacific islander black woman indian
american et cetera we don't need a court
that exactly matches the makeup of the
us in every turn every every sort of
demographic characteristic nor is it
even possible with only nine people on
the court but at a certain point when
you say wow we have 330 million people
in the country now
the supreme court's been around more
than 200 years it starts to get weird
that we have not had certain people on
the court
now
they start to play its identity over
qualifications they say we're ignoring
who are the most qualified people
because we're focused on identity
instead of qualifications and again
that's a terrible argument once again
we're a country of 331 million people
if i were to say or if joe biden were to
say i am going to pick the first former
sports oh
okay current or former sports team owner
who is a woman we would say wow that's
like a really small group there's not a
lot of female major sports team owners
it's like you know renee montgomery and
michelle williams from destiny's child
is a part owner of a team and jeannie
buss owns parts of multiple nba teams we
might be saying that's really weird that
identity designation is not
uh appealing to appearing to be a pool
of qualified people
joe biden is picking one black woman and
there are many qualified black women
there is no reason to believe
that by saying i'm going to pick a black
woman and it's going to be notable given
the history of the country in the
history of the court there's no reason
to believe that it's going to be a less
qualified individual you're picking from
among the many qualified black women it
is such a non-story
and that's me as a non-woke
non-identity person not identity
politics person telling you this but
they're gonna keep playing it up
and they're gonna make it into something
that it is not if you disagree with me i
would love to hear from you um
respectfully of course
um okay the u.s army after giving so
much notice and giving every opportunity
for service members to go and get
themselves vaccinated with the covet
vaccine is at the end of the grace
period and the us army is going to start
discharging covet vaccine refusers
effective immediately npr reporting
u.s army soldiers who refuse to be
vaccinated for covid will soon be
discharged the military branch announced
yesterday wednesday the army said it
will quote immediately begin separating
soldiers from the service who refuse to
be vaccinated or who don't have an
approved or pending request for
exemption
secretary of the army christine warmuth
said army ready readiness depends on
soldiers who are prepared to train
deploy fight and win our nation's wars
unvaccinated soldiers present risk to
the force and jeopardize readiness
soldiers who are discharged for refusing
to be vaccinated will not be eligible
for involuntary separation pay and may
even have to return unearned special or
incentive pay
now the right is framing this as
we are dramatically weakening i don't
know why i'm doing the alex jones voice
we are dramatically weakening
the military and we are going to be more
beta rather than alpha in fighting wars
which they claim they don't want to
fight anyway but as of january 26th as
the article points out 96 percent of
active duty troops were completely
vaccinated
uh 3 300 soldiers have refused
5 900 have temporary exemptions and um
those are temporary in the sense that
their requests are still being reviewed
this is really not a big deal it's time
you need a bunch of vaccines to be in
the military this is the latest vaccine
you need it's not controversial we've
gone through the list i'm not going to
do it again is it 10
15 depending on where you're serving it
can be closer to 20 different vaccines
that you have to get when you're in the
military if you won't follow a simple
service-wide vaccine mandate that is
like the 13th or the 18th or whatever
it's not unique it's not we've never had
any vaccine requirements and now here's
one you've got to get
they all got in line for all the other
vaccines when they enlisted um it's just
time to say you're not fit for military
service oh i'm not taking this one
vaccine because of my rights or my
religion or come on guys come on now one
thing that i heard from some service
members about and
i did a little research into this and it
does appear to be true
is um a bill was passed
taking uh dishonorable discharges off
the table for vaccine refusers
so what i'm hearing from some of our
viewers who are in the military uh is
that there are people who have been sort
of wanting to get out for a little while
and they're taking this as an
opportunity now again we're only talking
about 3 300 unvaccinated with no
exemption right now
so it's like a tiny tiny percentage of
individuals
and some fraction of those
may be refusing the vaccine not because
they're actually against it but because
they want
a way to get out without a dishonorable
discharge so
that may be a factor to some degree but
i i don't think it's a a dominant thing
but anecdotally it does seem to exist
from what i'm hearing but there's really
nothing controversial here it is not
going to affect overall military
readiness it's not going to affect uh in
any material way
the massive fighting force that the
united states has and it really
shouldn't even be getting the attention
that it's getting because it's not
never needed vaccines and now you do
like i said it's you always needed 12
now you need 13 or but depending on
where you're serving you needed 17.
now you need 18. it's not a big deal
and it shouldn't be made into one and
the military has been saying for a long
time this is exactly what we're going to
do
and now they're doing it it would be
more of a problem i would argue
if they said that this is what they were
going to do and then they failed to do
it
uh they promised this was the path and
they're doing it and it makes perfect
sense if you disagree with me let me
know you can find me on twitter at d
pacman we're going to take a very short
break we really have a fantastic program
for you today
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar that's why
you should check out our long time
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar
14 grams of protein and only four net
carbs so it's perfect if you're doing
low carb or keto or if like me you just
try to limit your sugar intake you can
build your own variety pack with flavors
like cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman
remember that the david pakman show does
depend on viewers and listeners like you
to support what we do every day
including our new thing sending
correspondence to trump rallies and
other political events to interview
people which i'll talk more about in a
moment you can sign up at
uh joinpackman.com get instant access to
the bonus show and the bonus show you
know for years i've been telling you the
bonus show is world famous uh which is
true
the bonus show is award-winning which is
true we give out the awards but they
they they still are awards but now i can
tell you and and accurately tell you
this is the bonus show
brutally attacked by conspiracy theorist
alex jones oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
right
i can think of no greater endorsement
for the bonus show than the fact that
alex jones has attacked it and uh you
can sign up at joinpakman.com
coupon code remember alex jones called
me a predator
new coupon code is predator 22.
okay predator 22
saves you big bucks
off of the bonus show at joinpakman.com
all right a few notable posts on the
david pakman show subreddit now here i'm
not selling you anything many times i am
selling you things here i'm not
you can go to davidpakman.com reddit
where nearly 34 000 of our viewers and
listeners have subscribed for free and
you can post about the show
you can talk to other viewers and
listeners about what's in the news
there's some things you're not allowed
to do because it's a little bit over the
line but there's a lot of things you can
do at davidpakman.com reddit
one user posted
on the scene correspondence has been my
favorite
addition
to the david pakman show seriously david
it's incredibly entertaining but also
wildly useful to get real feedback from
these events i don't know if josh or
luke wind up being recurring
correspondents but i loved watching them
maybe one of the larger events you or
pat could get out in the field too
there'd be some security concerns keep
this kind of segment going yeah the
point is taken the feedback to having
two people on the ground in conroe texas
for the rally was fantastic and the the
incredible thing is
because you all are everywhere all over
the country
it is very clear that if there's another
trump rally in you know tulsa oklahoma
maybe or wherever or if there is a um
i i don't know an anti-vaccine protest
in wherever
i think that we now have the audience
size where i can say hey
anybody in
berkeley california or wherever we'll
pay you
to go and interview people at these
events we don't have to fly people
around we don't need you know all these
different things and we can basically
just take
the the money because we want to
compensate these people for their time
that that's the appropriate thing to do
as we did with the texas rally
um and we can say well because you're
already there
the money goes for your time rather than
having to to put money into expenses i
think it's absolutely fantastic we're
going to keep trying to do it and the
one thing is we need to know about the
events early enough
it's hard to say hey can you go tomorrow
so in terms of trump rallies right now
we're not seeing anything else on
trump's calendar
um and we will we will see but one of
the most valuable things is
when right-wing media starts some new
story
whether it's about fouchy or biden or
whatever
by having these correspondents on the
ground we can immediately see
whether it's gotten to the trumpists and
whether they're aware of it and how
they're interpreting the new talking
point so it's a it's a fantastic thing
and we are going to keep uh doing it
okay another post on the subreddit david
should get in contact with carhartt
about being their spokesman and there's
a absolutely hur i described
so
carhartt
is a brand
that has
announced they their employees are
required to be vaccinated and it's sort
of a right-wing associated brand now i
very
uh
i don't know that i want to say
ignorantly but
i was having trouble describing what
carhartt is and i said carhartt is a
popular clothing brand
for people who are out doing work
chainsaws and whatever
i meant that it is a brand of clothing
that i believe also has it's not only
warm but it has like protective elements
where i think the material is such that
it has some protection if you regularly
work with sharp objects
uh i don't know anyway so someone made a
made a funny image of carhartt for
people out doing work chainsaws and
whatever but in all seriousness um
carhartt is not unique
there are tons of companies that require
their employees to be vaccinated and i
think
the reason that the carhartt vaccine
requirement triggered so many people is
that there is heavy association between
carhartt and sort of
working alpha right wing male ideology
um but carhartt's doing it carhartt has
said you got to be vaccinated and a lot
of right wingers now
burning their carhartt clothing although
what's funny is i think there are
carhartt items that are flame retardant
because of what they're designed for so
it was actually a prob it was difficult
to actually burn it
which just makes it all the more funny
join the discussion
at davidpakman.com
reddit all right this next story is a
very big deal
the january 6 trump riot committee the
committee investigating the january 6
2021 trump riots is uh quite frankly
doing a very good job of something that
is very difficult there are so many
different aspects to the trump riots
what was trump up to in the time leading
up to
what was going on within law enforcement
what were trump's kids doing what were
members of the house doing what were
members of the senate doing who knew
what when
um etc records that need to be obtained
all these different things the
um last two weeks
have generated new evidence for the
committee because donald trump's
reaction to the committee's actions
now appeared to be witness tampering and
in fact
congressman pete aguilar
said on cnn yesterday trump is tampering
with witnesses which is again scaling up
the criminality potential of what donald
trump has been up to so we have a cnn
report about this
january 6th committee member
says trump absolutely tampering with
witnesses as he continues to dangle
pardons let's take a look at uh this
video clip here
that lawyer represents other january 6
defendants and said that rhodes and
others would welcome a trump pardon is
trump tampering with witnesses when he's
talking about pardons when he's dangling
them in front of 1-6 defendants
absolutely and i think the question is
more for my colleagues on the other side
of the aisle you know where where are
they do they support this
when is enough enough when a mob is
chanting hang mike pence it wasn't
enough when the former president asked
brad raffensberger to find him eleven
thousand votes it wasn't enough right um
now he's you know dangling
pardons if he gets back in office for
individuals will that be enough or will
there be more collective amnesia
you know i just don't know where the
floor is these days on that where is the
floor and what is the bottom or however
it is that you want to describe it and
what's being referred to here and what's
funny is this isn't even the first time
that donald trump is dangling pardons in
a way that could be seen as witness
tampering remember that back with um
during the russia probe where you had
paul manafort
uh carter page
roger stone all these different people
being investigated and interviewed and
many subsequently charged uh for lying
to the fbi or different things donald
trump did the exact same thing he talked
about those who are staying strong
and he talked in a circuitous sort of
roundabout way about the possibility of
pardons
it could have been argued at that point
and many legal experts did argue that's
a form of witness tampering you were
signaling to these individuals if you
don't cooperate
i may pardon you in the future if you
don't cooperate there may be good things
coming and if you do cooperate you're
going to be on the list of bad boys so
to speak and you're not no longer going
to be in my good graces or whatever the
case may be
here donald trump is doing a very
similar thing with the trump rioters
themselves
it's different because there's a really
good chance trump is never going to
pardon any of them and and this is sort
of like multi-step
it's not at all clear that donald trump
will be the republican nominee in 2024
if he is the republican nominee it's not
at all clear that donald trump will win
the presidential election in 2024. if
trump wins the 2024 president
presidential election there is no
guarantee that he will actually pardon
any of these people
and so not only is it another attempt to
potentially influence the behavior of
the rioters uh and of those this is an
important addition it's not only about
influencing the behavior of the rioters
themselves in their cases
but also of republicans
more so in the house but in theory in
the house and senate and other people
around trump in general about
cooperation with the committee or the
trump rights it's a bigger signal
but
it's not even clear that trump really
intends to follow through on this and uh
you can you can make the argument as
pete aguilar does uh on cnn that it is a
form of witness tampering now the
obvious question is well so should we
expect a criminal referral to the
department of justice um it it and it is
not
because donald trump will go to prison i
maintain trump is not going to prison
but at what point do we say
the facts just point to there should be
a criminal referral from the january 6th
committee to the department of justice
and then put it on the department of
justice to decide
we will or won't investigate we will or
won't charge put it on merit garland to
actually
sort of be pushed into having to do
something when it comes to this when is
enough enough
and um consider
with hillary clinton vis-a-vis benghazi
endless hearings special investigation
hearing report all these different
things
demanding charges demanding hillary
clinton be locked up absent any charges
ignoring their stated principle of the
value of due process and
constitutionality and the rule of law
and law and order and all these things
there wasn't even anything there and
they were saying lock up hillary clinton
it seems at minimum here uh there is
more than enough
evidence and factual basis for a
criminal referral to the department of
justice and then let's see how the
department of justice deals with it
i don't expect this to stop
and we continue to follow the now more
than 700 cases 700 defendants
in the trump riots now 13 almost 13
months to the day beyond that date the
sentences are starting to come in
and uh we will see where it ends up but
without a doubt
this is arguably another instance of
witness tampering and if you're trump
if there were no repercussions to the
earlier witness tampering with the
russia probe
why would you behave any differently now
of course you wouldn't and that's part
of this entire thing we'll have that
clip of congressman pete aguilar
on our instagram you can find that at
david pakman show we're going to take a
quick break and uh we've got a really
interesting interview coming up not
about the 1
but about the 9.9
what does that mean it's a very
interesting group culturally and
economically
and we're going to talk about that after
this short break
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to
joinpacman.com and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
today i'm going to be speaking with
matthew stewart who's a philosopher and
author of several books including most
recently the 9.9 percent the new
aristocracy that is entrenching
inequality and warping our culture uh
really appreciate having you on matthew
thank you
yeah it's great to be here david thanks
for having me so we often hear about the
one percent we hear about the 0.1
percent uh we hear about the bottom 90
percent many times or the bottom 50
percent in discussions of of economics
and society and culture
what is significant about this 9.9
that made you want to study and write
about it specifically
so let's not forget that the 0.1 is
actually driving the wealth inequality
and the bottom 90 is the group that's
losing so the
there's two interesting things about the
9.9 percent one is that it's actually
holding on to its wealth so that's i
think really important
and then the other thing is that it
plays a much bigger role in driving our
our values and our culture
so that's i think what makes them
especially interesting because i think
we're all
part of it even if we're not financially
part of it can you talk about the ways
in which that group drives culture
yeah i mean so for example uh in
education it's pretty straightforward um
you know the the the plan for for making
it into the 9.9 percent
um today is to go to college and go to a
good college and get a good degree and
so on um and that kind of plan made a
lot of sense when college wasn't
expensive when a lot of it was publicly
paid for
and when there were jobs for people who
got those kind of degrees but all those
realities are gone
and yet the value system is if anything
even more entrenched so there's even
more emphasis on you can make it if you
just go to the right college and sort of
figure out how the system works and then
it turns out of course that the people
who succeed in that are the ones who
already start with a leg up whose
parents are already in the nine point
nine percent
what are the um economic uh just what
what what's the line for entering that
group that nine point nine percent in
terms of where is the 90th percentile in
terms of income and wealth and where how
far up does it reach
yeah so um but let me also just qualify
and say that you know we don't get too
fetishized about the numbers because
they move and also it's not just about
the numbers it's about relative
proportions but um you know basically
you you need about 1.2 million dollars
in net worth to make it into the top 10
decile or the 9.9 of the wealth
distribution
and your income should be in 120 000
um plus range so that that's what kind
of gets you into it financially and then
at the top end um obviously it's it's
different as you get to the top but
about 20 million will push you out the
top
in in
wealth and you know sort of um
uh 500 000 or so in income which you
know sounds like a lot but in fact when
you compare it to the very large sums
they're going into the 0.1 it's actually
pretty small so it's a group is more
homogeneous than people like to think
now what's interesting is certainly
i would guess the vast majority of the
bottom half of that group would consider
themselves middle class and many who
live in the most
expensive cities would would absolutely
insist that that they are middle class
is that part is that culturally relevant
that so much of that group considers
itself middle class and is it accurate
in some sense
yeah so what's happening is is the
hollowing out of the middle class but
the ideas are about
you know 20 or 30 years behind the
economic reality so um
um a lot of people in in this 9.9
percent even in the bottom part
they don't get how wealthy they are
relative to the rest of society they
don't quite get
um how um how much better they do have
it and of course part of the reason why
they don't get it is because they're
also being stressed i mean it's it's
pretty hard to stay in that group you
have to work really hard
um and you know get some lucky breaks
and be in the right place at the right
time and so on so um
i think there's a significant um
misperception in in the group which is
how else they are and a lot of this
shows up in surveys you ask people you
know how much do the people at the top
make and they say oh well you know the
average ceo makes a million dollars a
year and of course that's that's
preposterous and the average ceo makes
17 or 18 million a year for a
top 500 company so um
i think there's a lot of misperceptions
and and the one you mentioned the middle
class illusion is is really big one
can you talk a little bit about the
racial makeup of this group that you're
describing generally speaking
yeah and pretty simply it's mostly white
i mean um
it's about 90 white um as against you
know depends how you measure at 65 to 70
percent of the general population um
there definitely are
people of color uh in in the 9.9 percent
a significant group but in relative to
the representation of the total
population it's significantly lower so
um i think the black shares about 1.7
of the nine point nine percent as
against about 13 of the general
population latinos roughly similar
in terms of um political power i mean we
understand the dynamics of money and
political power in the united states
generally speaking
but that top 9.9
is much bigger in terms of population by
definition than the top 0.1 percent in
terms of aggregate power and that
doesn't mean it's being wielded
effectively but in terms of aggregate
power what is the power dynamic between
that top 0.1 percent and the following
9.9
yeah it's it's um
the 9.9 presents this big political
problem especially for the democratic
party frankly because
um that group now is is leaning
uh blue it's not completely rude but
it's it's more so than the general
population where's the top 0.1
notwithstanding all the
nonsense about limousine liberals
actually functionally leans very much to
the right
um
and um
and the dynamic between them it's a
really great question it's
you know on the one hand 9.9 is
fundamentally dependent on the 0.1
percent uh economically but on the other
hand culturally
um
there there is a a big gap and a
significant part shifting left is aware
of that and tries to pull away the big
danger for the democratic party and the
left
is that
this
group which is i think has a
disproportionate weight in left politics
um doesn't necessarily understand or
share the interests of the other 90 of
the population
so they they tend to skew
the left in ways that can be um
ultimately uh go against the interests
of the large part of the population and
sort of work indirectly for the top oh
that's interesting so let's see if we
can think about that a little so you've
got so the top 0.1 percent is
leans overtly to the republican side and
it's sort of clear
that the economic interests of that
group in terms of the policy they want
is not good for the bottom 90 percent it
sounds like you're saying with this the
following 9.9 percent nominally these
are folks who identify more as democrats
than republicans and believe themselves
to lean more left than they lean right
but maybe
without even really knowing it the
policies they want or the status quo
that they reinforce is also not good for
that bottom 90 percent
yeah i mean a classic example for me is
is the real estate game so the um uh
we don't actually pay a lot of attention
to that this issue in national politics
but it actually drives a lot of our
culture and it drives a lot of the
issues that we have the the huge
segregation economic and racial
in our neighborhoods and the the role of
the 9.9 and that i would say on
aggregate is really pretty regressive
because what it ends up doing is is
saying oh the issue isn't you know our
neighborhoods the issue is has to do
with um you know any number of other
things you know personal prejudices with
education with
um you know economic policies that we're
that interests us more but in fact the
9.9 tends to ultimately come down very
heavily in favor of very restrictive
zoning
and other very restrictive land use
policies that that drive up the price of
housing that have created an
affordability housing crisis that
reinforce segregation dynamics that
reinforce educational segregation
dynamics
and so they end up being you know very
regressive and it's something that the
9.9 percent i think intellectually the
more self-aware members are are on to
this but
uh functionally the way they actually
act um ends up you know reproducing
these these divisions that in turn
increase inequality and work to the
benefit of the 0.1 percent one of the
things that often comes up in
conversation with people who do well but
are not in the top 0.1 percent and maybe
not even in the top 1 percent so maybe
we're talking about
90th to 98th percentile to kind of
imagine again you know as we're talking
about these are not exact exact
delineations but there's often the
feeling among the 90 to 98 percent that
hey
the very top doesn't pay enough in taxes
and we do need to do things for the
bottom 90
but also the taxes are a little too high
on us the 90 to the 98. can you talk a
little bit about
that dynamic and and really
where some of these lines should be in
terms of taxation
yeah so there there's a grain of truth
in that it turns out that the
the real tax rate when you throw it all
in you have the federal state local you
look at capital and income and so on the
real tax rate for at the very top is
lower it's it's dramatically and
absurdly lower than it is for the upper
middle class and so on so vis-a-vis the
0.1 percent yeah the 9.9
is getting screwed like the rest of
society um
there's another side of it though that's
a little harder for people than 9.9 to
grasp and that's that
our tax system is so um arcane and
complicated that it ends up indirectly
subsidizing a lot of people invisibly so
you know a classic case point is the
mortgage interest deduction
but there are many other bits and pieces
like that that have the effect of um
subsidizing the 9.9 percent
in ways that are kind of invisible so
people in in that group
think that their taxes are actually
higher than they are another going back
to real estate that's another kind of
invisible subsidy we have um
uh
we notwithstanding the fact that we do
have property uh municipal property
taxes we basically don't capture the the
implicit rental value of real estate and
so people who own their own homes end up
getting an indirect tax subsidy but
they're completely unaware of this
they think they're geniuses for having
bought into the real estate market when
they did
and so they're kind of unaware that some
of the money that's coming their way is
really an indirect tax subsidy so it's a
really complicated picture and of course
you know i'm sure you'd agree if we
could wave magic want we'd replace the
current taxes to have something
radically more progressive
um and a lot more fair yeah i've had
very interesting conversations with
folks who say
you know i don't really make that much
and i'm touching the 33 federal tax
bracket and then when i live if i live
in new york or california or
massachusetts then you're throwing five
to five to 10 on top of that and i'll
often say to these folks listen you
don't have to tell me exactly what you
make but
understand that you're touching that top
33 percent but not all of your income is
taxed at that because we have you know
these are these are brackets
marginal tax brackets and then you've
got your standard deduction
and you have a mortgage and you've got
you know all these different things you
should really look at that first page of
your 1040 which says total tax
divide it by your income and you are
going to find a shockingly low number
and many times it's 17 18
federally overall
and
the these are folks absolutely in that
9.9 percent who themselves don't really
have an understanding of the degree to
which they are paying federal taxes
yeah but
but let's just not forget that you know
the big money is at the very top of
course and the big solution here
absolutely is actually to go after this
yeah yeah another two or three points
for someone making a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars a year
has almost no impact compared to what
we're talking about in the point one
percent without a doubt
right right but then let me also mention
on the other end because this is
something that happens when we talk
about the 9.9 we forget about people
that are at the at the other end of the
economic spectrum um
we don't think about sales taxes as a
big issue generally if you're remember
the 9.9 but that's actually a pretty
significant hit to a lot of um people
with lower incomes um we don't think
about the um the fica you know the the
uh payroll tax deduction but that you
know if you've got if you've got a
minimum wage job that's a big big chunk
of your income so um things are are much
more regressive than than people
understand in the 9.9 without question
um the book is fascinating it's called
the 9.9 percent the new aristocracy that
is entrenching inequality and warping
our culture we've been speaking with the
book's author matthew stewart really
appreciate your time today
yeah great to be here david thank you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right let's talk
about the patriarchy a little bit this
is the this is probably the favorite
topic of my audience my audience just
loves talking about
the patriarchy no that's not true
so we're gonna look at a clip it's an
interesting clip jason whitlock was on
tucker carlson's daytime program now the
difference between tucker carlson's
daytime program and nighttime program
is that tucker
wears less formal clothes on the daytime
program but it's just as wacky it's
really no different jason whitlock is a
journalist who came from the sports
world and has become more and more of a
cultural critic the right wing
really has taken to jason whitlock he's
sort of like an anti-woke
tell it like it is type guy and the
things he tells like they are as he sees
them
are very often wrong and extraordinarily
reactionary
and jason whitlock on the tucker program
talked about how not only is he probably
a sexist but that the patriarchy is a
good thing and sort of like it's all
good because we need to keep women in
their roles
now this is a clip from 2022 it's not a
clip from 1952. and i know many of you
might say wow the video quality is so
good for what we would expect to hear in
1952. no this is from this week and um
tucker carlson
tucker seems to know he can't agree with
um uh
the guest openly because that could be
problematic for him but he does the
thing where he goes he says that's not
an opinion you're allowed to have right
now and so he's kind of like indirectly
saying like wow that's an opinion you
can really get in trouble for but i
don't disagree with it one bit so let's
just get into the clip and then we'll
we'll kind of pause as needed
but i probably am a sexist pig so i
could care less if i'm called that but
the patriarchy now he should be saying i
couldn't care less you would think a
journalist like jason whitlock would
know that but that's okay this isn't
about that it's about the substance good
thing
it's it's it's what god intended
uh men are supposed to lead
men are supposed to be out front
taking risks
um we're responsible that you know i
have some ministers on my show every
wednesday and we talk about it all the
time
and again this if you have a biblical
worldview it's shocking that the
ministers agree with the patriarchal
view huh
uh
in the garden adam and eve when things
go haywire
god shows up
and calls up adam where are you at
hey
basically he says i'm excuse my language
ain't right here
adam what are you doing
i left you in charge
and that's god is looking down at us
right now
at men and just what are you doing
why are you laying down
why are you pretending that hillary
clinton
kamala harris stacy abrams how do none
of them know how to pronounce kamala
harris by the way that they can save us
they can save this world this is
lunacy it's out of her role completely
and
uh i'm sorry if that paints me as a
sexist pig but it's what i believe well
that's just i mean that's just an
epithet designed to make you be quiet
but i guess i right listen the you know
when you talk about how these women are
not fit to lead because they're women
and that they're trying to be out of
their roles
um when people call you a sexist they're
just trying to silence you it's just
it's just an epithet what i wonder why
why is that why are you not allowed to
have that opinion why is that so
controversial that was the opinion of
every society like from the beginning of
time until about 20 minutes ago now that
is that is actually what i want to focus
on what tucker says there
there's this bigger movement
about the natural patriarchy and this is
a movement that wants to explain
uh what might appear to be
um
unfair inequality
when it comes to gender
or discrimination against women
um
that they want to explain it away by
saying there is a
natural patriarchy whether it's
um
biological or genetic or whatever the
case meant neurological and so that that
this is a very important movement and
they wrongly believe
the way tucker carlson says that it's
always been the way of humanity until as
he says 20 minutes ago until the woke
era until recently and it's just not
true now as many of you know
i have no interest in repeating
um
tropes and talking points on this show
that aren't true so for example
when you don't hear this anymore
that much because i don't know society
has moved on but remember 77 cents on
the dollar you would always hear women
make 77 cents on the dollar compared to
men
it wasn't true
and we studied it and what we found out
was that women made about 91 cents on
the dollar now it's still an inequality
and there's a lot to look at and it's
well when when uh what are some of the
reasons why that is and let's explore it
and what portion of that is due to
discrimination on a gender basis and
what
listen let's explore all of it but i'm
not going to repeat 77 cents when i know
it to be 91 cents okay so i have no
attachment to any of these talking
points the natural patriarchy thing is
just not true
first of all if you just look in the
modern era
on jobs
there is no evidence that women are less
capable
of jobs and social positions that men
predominantly hold
i'm totally open to exploring interest
level in some of those positions among
gender lines and when we talk about well
there's certain jobs that men versus
women are more interested in i'm totally
fine having the conversation as to
whether the difference in interest is
societally imposed by stereotypes
or for some inherent reason
the right loves to say oh leftists don't
want to ask these questions ask them i
mean look when you think back to the
larry summers harvard comment
about uh something about math makes
women less suited or like whatever he
said
i have no problem exploring whether
there is some basis on which women are
less suited to math i've seen no
evidence that that's the case and so if
we don't have evidence we shouldn't
repeat it but the idea that these things
are taboo
they're not taboo for me and there is no
evidence that women are less capable of
the jobs and social positions that men
predominantly hold that i have seen now
it's also fine to acknowledge there are
biological differences between men and
women biological men don't breastfeed
biological men can't get pregnant
but this idea of the natural state of
the patriarchy is a lame one and it is
also a relatively recent thing there's
some very interesting evidence
that patriarchal societies
don't date back more than 10 000 years
humans appear to have been
significantly egalitarian
for a very long time if you go back and
look further and one reason that we we
suspect that is the relatively similar
size of human males and females yes
human males are bigger than females but
the disparity is much smaller of all of
the great apes and that is a clue it's
not proof but it's a clue
that male dominance
uh does not seem to have been as
important a driving force in the
development of humanity as people like
tucker carlson and jason whitlock might
might propose so you know it's not even
clear i needed to give this much
explanation but the things which jason
whitlock and tucker are just kind of
casually ranting about inciting god and
oh well you know they don't allow you to
say this anymore whatever
these are topics of academic interest
and we do actually know more than what
jason whitlock's pastor says
uh or minister whoever whoever is on his
show so you know
i i don't know that uh
there's there's much value in this
program that tucker does but they
actually are raising interesting topics
their understanding of them is
completely wrong but these are
interesting topics for sure i want to
look at a clip now of a radical
republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor-green
i'm being interviewed by alex jones on
infowars now as many of you know alex
jones recently attacked me thank your
lucky stars every day you're not dave
pagman right oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad so
alex jones really doesn't like me but he
really likes marjorie taylor green and
that tells us a lot about marjorie
taylor greene marjorie taylor green in
one minute yesterday while being
interviewed by alex jones um told so
many lies
that some are likening this to a
psychotic break
um this is a sitting member of congress
guys this is this is someone who's
currently a member of congress
and the funniest part is her starting by
saying
everything going on with covet is mental
illness let's take a listen this is
truly mental illness now i know she said
mental illness she means mental illness
guys trust me wearing a mask today after
two years of this chinese virus that has
infected our country um this man-made
chinese virus that dr fauci sent our tax
dollars to and contributed to but
i mean contributed
mental uh
it's it's [ __ ] just visibly struggling
to speak people still wearing masks i
mean it's truly mentally ill we know the
masks don't work and the vaccines don't
work now both of those statements are
untrue
masks do work
those lame gators that people pull over
their face
and cloth masks don't work that well
if you've got two people wearing n95s i
mean this has been studied extensively
if one person is infected and one
person's not and both are wearing n95s
the odds of transmission are very very
low if people aren't wearing masks the
odds of transmission go up uh you know
who knows how many times i don't want to
understate it but they go up
dramatically
vaccines work new data suggests that you
are 97 times
more likely to die of covid right now
if you have no vaccines versus if you
have three doses
so what what she's saying is not true
it's not even close to true people that
are vaccinated are still getting coveted
now of course that's true
but it ignores the reality
that if you're unvaccinated
you're 97 times more likely to you know
it's exhausting at this point guys but i
think that people really have blood on
their hands that have stopped the
prescriptions of ivermectin refuse
people who have had sick family members
in the hospital of not being able to
take ivermectin now remember ivermectin
has not been demonstrated to be
effective against covid i would love it
if ivermectin
z pax
hydroxychloroquine zinc
whatever i would love it if that was
effective for covid these are cheap
ubiquitous things i have no
ideological opposition
but they've not been demonstrated to
work against covet or any other kind of
life-saving treatment or therapy i mean
i truly think that we need to
investigate all these people and
investigate the deaths that are reported
on the vares system and hold people
accountable now the vares system is
another darling of the american right
remember anybody can report anything
they want to the vayer system well but
david that would be against the law
uh people could get in trouble for that
is anybody getting in trouble for the
false reports no so anybody can report
anything to the vare system and even
honest reports to the vayer system about
people who died six weeks after getting
a vaccine
when you have hundreds of millions of
people getting vaccinated including
elderly folks and sick folks of course
some of them are going to die within six
weeks of getting the vaccine and they
would have died within six weeks anyway
and it can have nothing to do with covet
even never mind the vaccine so
she's wrong about everything she's you
know alex berenson is sort of the the
most the wrongest man
on the pandemic
uh marjorie taylor green is sort of like
the wrongest woman on the pandemic
because it's dr fauci and anyone at the
cdc or anyone involved that stopped
life-saving treatments and therapies and
people died well i think they're guilty
of murder right not giving ivermectin
makes you guilty of murder and by the
way why do all these right-wingers
instead of saying dr fauci they say dr
falchi i i just
why can't they just pronounce things the
way they are uh so marjorie taylor green
dangerously unhinged and the remember
the messages
member of congress one of 435 and
almost certain to be re-elected to her
seat in georgia we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
i am hoping
that today
we are closing the books on the me
leaving the country saga
i was asked if you left the country
because things got bad where would you
go and so i gave an answer and then i
was told you're abandoning us you're not
a team player i'm canceling my
membership because i can't support
someone who would just leave if things
got bad and i had to say no no no guys
i'm not planning on leaving i'm not
planning on leaving i was asked if you
were to leave where would you go um and
then i was told oh but you sound like a
jew trader jews who take their capital
elsewhere
um okay let's hope that this voicemail
is the final note on this entire leaving
the country thing
so those people to all those people that
you say who contacted you via email yes
to let you know their dismay anger
discussed
or threatening to or actually cancelling
their membership because they consider
you to be some kind of a trader some
kind of a jew trader uh they're banning
abandoning us or banning abandoning your
country blah blah blah
at least half of those people would do
the very same thing if they were able to
i think a lot of those people who
express negative thoughts towards you in
email
are the people who can't leave because
they're not able to leave they don't
have the wherewithal to lead that may be
and they're angry and resentful for that
so there's that
uh i think you
addressed the question quite well
towards the end
uh you don't need to apologize
any any normal person
if facebook extreme circumstances
externally in his or her own country
would it such as human nature it's
survival
desperate people do desperate things
it's not a question of being loyal or
patriotic [ __ ] that
we're a nation of strangers
if any country was a country a nation of
strangers it's the united states because
the last thing we are
is united
so
don't let them trouble you
i hope you can make up any revenue you
might have lost from those muse
who felt
because they can't do what you do
they have to be
they have to be uh
engage in retribution and despite
them
in the horse they wrote in on wow
you do what you have to do and by the
way that's not to say you can't continue
your show that you that you can't
broadcast to people in america from a
different country
technology just to do that yeah not only
that i've done it and there have been
there have been stretches of time where
i've been out of the us and the people i
just i didn't announce it because there
was no reason to announce it but nobody
had any idea uh so it's i don't think
it's not really a question of being able
to do the show so let's hope that that's
the final note on this leaving the
country thing i have no plan to leave
the country we will talk on today's
bonus show about the um resignation of
cnn's president over a consensual
relationship with an employee we will
talk about a push to make the lunar new
year a federal holiday and we will we
will actually talk about jury
deliberations in the roy moore
defamation case remember this is the
bonus show much maligned by alex jones
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad right what an
endorsement and uh i invite you to sign
up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access and i will see
you on the bonus show momentarily
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman